so just let us know how what the
evidence
shows on how well vaccines are currently
working
against the new variant and whether or
not there's any discrepancy or if some
vaccines work better than others
all right sophie yes uh so important to
say that
uh difficult to be very definite about
this particular variant
and the vaccines but we can say quite a
lot from what we know already
from all the different versions of the
virus and the different vaccines
that we've been studying through the
year and the one piece of reassuring
news
is that we've seen consistently good
protection against severe disease
with different vaccines and different
viruses so far um
and so i think we all are cautiously
optimistic
that that will continue to be the case
also with this
uh this version of the virus excuse me
what we're left with is how well the
vaccines will be able to impact on
milder disease
and in particular impact on transmission
of the infection in the population
so that remains to be found out but i
think people should
feel reasonably confident that if
they're fully
vaccinated their risks of serious
illness will be much reduced
uh also against this version of the
virus
if the the uncertainty is around
transmission or mild
disease does that really matter i guess
it would be my question if it doesn't
necessarily then lead to
hospitalizations or deaths should we be
a bit more relaxed about whether or not
the disease can keep spreading
yes it does matter because it's through
transmission in the population
that the virus finds the people who are
still vulnerable
there are older people and vulnerable
people who've not been immunized
there are amongst them as as sir mark
walcott was just saying
individuals in whom the vaccination has
been given but
it hasn't produced good protection and
the more the virus is moving around in
the population
the more chances it has to find those
people and
with them ending up in hospital or very
seriously ill
so transmission really does matter um
and as we move down through the
population
that is increasingly the aim of the
vaccine program to try and
achieve population immunity uh and and
prevent
and provide that indirect protection and
and prevent hospitalizations that way as
well
given impacting transmissibility is so
important like affecting the spread
of the virus and do you think it would
be a good idea to really prioritize
vaccines
in the areas where we've seen hot spots
with the india variant
yeah we had a lot of discussion about
this last week and i think the real
concern is that because
vaccine supply at the moment is the rate
limiting step
if you start moving vaccine around from
one place to another or from one group
to another
um what you end up doing is is
disrupting
the overall protection of the population
that you need
two or three weeks down the line when
the vaccines have had a chance to work
and you end up chasing the virus around
and always arriving too late
vaccines are a really useful tool to
prevent
waves of infection but they're not
terribly good at
preventing them once they're in full
swing if you like
so our conclusion was that we would
probably do more harm than good
if we started making the program more
complicated
more difficult to deliver and basically
slow things down elsewhere
another big decision that the jcbi has
taken is about this dosing
advice and this change to the
recommendation that the 12-week gap
for the over 50s should be cut to eight
weeks
we've been told though haven't we that
the optimum gap
is 12 weeks that you you get better
immunity if you leave it that little bit
longer
was that a difficult decision to make
was it was a was it unanimous on the
jcvi and what's the thinking behind it
uh it's certainly a difficult decision
to make because as you've correctly
implied
it you know you're there's a gain side
and there's a lost side to this
um the the fact is that the reduction in
dose interval
is relatively small uh in practice the
second doses were mostly being given
around 10 or 11 weeks
and now it'll be around eight or nine
weeks that will in fact
mean that the size of the booster
response that people get will be
marginally reduced
uh by having their dose earlier but they
will get it earlier and there's a
substantial additional protection you
get from that second dose
and we're now in a time of high risk
when people really need to have that
protection as
as quickly as possible so yes it's it's
a balancing act
but on on balance i think we all agreed
that this was something that could be
done
uh the folks in nhs england uh were able
to tell us that the logistics
could rise to this challenge and i think
it will do something to reduce the risks
of this anticipated third wave that
could follow
a dissemination of this variant the
size of the booster response will be
marginally reduced i mean
people will get a little bit less
protection from the vaccine is what
you're saying
very marginally yes what's clear is that
spacing the dose out
gives you a bigger response when you do
get that second dose
but you have to take into account the
risk you're facing now
when you decide what to do and people we
really want people to be as well
protected as possible
in a month's time just in case this
variant is raging around the country and
causing real problems
so was the jcvr unanimous in the
decision
yeah i'm glad to say throughout the year
we've been meeting
every week several times and we've
always been able to achieve a clear
consensus we've never had
real conflict within the committee it's
a very functional committee
everyone listens to everyone else and
we've always been able to reach
joint decisions on matters of this high
importance
yeah always good to hear that definitely
um you're talking about
uh supply being the rate limiting uh
factor
and does speeding up the dosing for uh
the over the 50s put
any of the other roll out targets at
risk
happily not so what we're doing at the
moment
is using our supplies of the astrazeneca
vaccine
almost entirely for giving second doses
those are available the logistics in
terms of delivery
was feasible and because we've got such
an
amazingly efficient mechanism for making
appointments and people
showing up so promptly and reliably we
can do this
without really having any impact or
negative impact on any other aspect of
the program
if it really is a race and does feel
like it's a race that's what matt
hancock was saying you'll talk about the
importance of getting vaccinations out
as well as quickly as possible
could the jcvi look again at this
recommendation that the under 40s should
be offered non-astrazeneca jabs if it
means that it could speed up that roll
out
yes absolutely that's that's on the
agenda
and if necessary that's something that
could be done when we
expressed a preference for
non-astrazeneca vaccines for this age
group
it was done in a very provisional way on
the basis of everything going absolutely
right
and if the evidence shows that the
risk-benefit balance for people in their
30s
is to be offered that vaccine then
absolutely
that that recommendation will be changed
at the moment we don't think that's
necessary
but it could could well become a
recommendation in the future
that's interesting to hear and also
looking ahead to the future and
president biden
laid out plans last week to vaccinate 12
to 15 year olds quite
soon what's the latest on the policy on
vaccinating children in the united
kingdom well we've just started having
discussions about this clearly it's
something that needs to be thought about
but i think the consensus at the moment
is that children are very much
not the priority very few children
getting ill
uh very limited amounts of transmission
being shown to be
occurring in schools despite having
reopened
um and and so the real focus at the
moment remains
with older people and people who are
vulnerable including children of course
who are vulnerable so that they get
immunized
and immunizing children is something
very much for the future and not for the
present